foreign
reached out to me and asked if her
husband could adopt my daughter asking
if I would be willing to sign over my
parental rights
and uh allow him to adopt
what's up this is the Dr John deloney
show and I'm John man I'm so glad that
you're here the greatest mental health
and relationship and parenting podcast
ever recorded
right here I'm glad that you're giving
us your most precious resource which is
your time if you want to be on the show
go to John deloney.com ask and fill out
the form let us know what's going on in
your life and we'll get back in touch
with you and we'll have you on the show
can't wait for it
um okay so I'm super jazzed today we're
going to talk about
something that's near and dear to my
heart and it's one of the top questions
I get asked all the time on the on the
Instagrams on the Facebooks on the phone
calls emails however people can get a
hold of me my friends ask
supplements supplements which
supplements should I take why should I
take them we don't even need to be
taking all the questions about
supplements and normally on these type
of shows the conversations get highly
highly technical so I'm Gonna Leave the
the technical aspects of all of this to
the Andrew huberman's and the Peter
Attias of the world much smarter guys
who are med school professors and
medical doctors
I'm going to talk about supplements
today
um in a way that I can understand it and
I'm not the sharpest tool in the shed
and then I'm going to
let you know about a new partnership I
got that is going to
change you and your family so
here's the deal people take supplements
for a million different reasons some of
them are because of fads right some
study on the John test show will come
out or some study on Yahoo News will
come out and then everyone will will be
like oh I got to take this some of them
uh some YouTuber is like bro you should
has some Financial stake in his own
supplement line
um and he wants you to to take all these
things or your DACA doctor recommends it
and doctors sometimes get a swath panel
meaning
they just say you know what you should
have some vitamin C and some vitamin D
and some zinc and then people go off to
Walgreens and they or they'll go to
Walmart and they'll buy the cheapest
thing they can find or they'll find
um the brown bottle that looks like it's
like ancient medicine it's like some
kind of potion and that looks like it's
gonna be more like yeah
um and they take that stuff some people
take supplements because there's
possibly less nutrients in food now that
we're genetically modifying whatever and
you got on that rabbit hole
um they have more chronically stressful
Lifestyles pollution all kinds of
different reasons um some people take
them for training advantages or sporting
advantages or to help augment or
um augment
um neurological function right cognition
uh smart drugs they call them nootropics
um so here's the thing you need to know
about supplements the industry is the
Wild Wild West
the number of studies that have come
back showing we just like the third
party testing groups will go grab
supplements off random grocery store
shelves off local corner store shelves
off Walmart shelves whatever and they
will test them and the number of
different
chemical compounds they find in these
things how it says you know it's got a
500 000 you know
milligrams of vitamin D in there and
there's eight milligrams right like
whatever
it's the Wild West it's not even like
the FDA which we all know is just
knocking out of the park the last few
years it's it's simply
like make it up as you go and it is
causing people to take the wrong things
it's causing professional athletes to
test positive for things that they're
they didn't intentionally ingest
um it's causing people to waste a ton of
money
and most supplements I'm sad to say are
trash trash they're no good they're no
good
um
years ago years ago
um
I was introduced to a company called
Thorne
t-h-o-r-n-e and their promise was we are
the purest supplements on the planet and
we have multiple third-party testers and
they
um have Partnerships with the Mayo
Clinic with companies all over the world
saying we are not just going to put
labels on things so and and have you
trust us we're going to have third party
testers run studies and they are going
to show you that what we say is true and
then they became the athlete supplement
of choice because athletes could take
them and trust that what they were
taking was actually in the supplement
and they weren't going to test positive
for some sort of anabolic agent that
they weren't allowed to be having
um so I started years ago
taking Thorn supplements
here's why I do it
um a couple of reasons one I've had
multiple consults with doctors over the
years and I've always worked pretty
closely with doctors and I'm into woo
stuff and all that but
um I run pretty hard and y'all heard me
say my wife says man you're a lot
um but I put my body through it
um
so when I run stress tests my stress
biomarkers are very high they're not as
clean as they should be
um this week I wrote this down this week
I'll be in three different states
multiple time zones last week I spoke to
uh three uh three different of speaking
of uh speaking engagements for hundreds
of people at one corporate event then
flew to Los Angeles for another event
I've got a writing deadline going I've
got two little kids that I'm running
around with I have a battle the bands
heavy metal event this weekend that's
gonna be in front of a couple thousand
people then I get on a plane to go to a
funeral in another state like I'm all
over the place
and so I run hard and that's just I'm on
this end of the spectrum but before I
was doing that I was just a parent of
two little kids trying to get my job
done trying to get my exercise in and so
this has been a pattern my whole life I
run pretty hard and most of the people I
know run pretty hard and I work out
every day I have a I don't always sleep
well I don't I don't always eat well so
here's the thing
um
I take supplements because I've sat down
and looked at my blood markers and I
know that when I take
I don't know I only almost exclusively
take Thorn stuff I can see the
difference in my blood markers I can
feel it over time of course but
um I can see the difference and I am
playing a long game when it comes to my
health I trust Thorne so much that these
are the supplements the only supplements
I give to my kids and I do it every day
these are supplements I recommend to all
my friends I think half the people in
the booth are on Thorn now
um it's just what I when people ask me
this is I say this is the best this is
who who I who I use and I've been
spending my own money on Thorn
supplements for year after year after my
wife says one day when we can't afford
our kids to go to college that um maybe
Thorne will send them to school because
that's how much money I've sent to them
over the years I also like testing stuff
on myself just n equals one I wonder
what happens if I take this for 60 days
or something like that so um
foreign
I take them on a regular basis I take
them they're important to me and um I
also know there's a lot of garbage out
there so the most common question I get
is what do I take what do I take what do
I take what do I take here are the thorn
products that I take on a daily basis um
and I want to say this with one caveat
if you run out and just buy what I'm
telling you right now
um that's the dumbest thing you could do
because you and I have different bodies
clearly because
um
I was gonna say I'm a smoke show but I'm
not everyone in the booth is like no
you're not
um
I've got different Health priorities
I've got different stressors I've got
different life than you do I've got also
got different genetics than you do I've
got different so don't just run out and
copy everything here which is a common
thing I used to do back in the day
um but I will tell you some a couple
things I think every single grown-up
should be on I'll tell you what I give
to my kids every day
um and then I'll the most important one
is the Sleep
um the things that I've dialed in to
help me with sleep and I'm still messing
with it here and there and then at the
end I'll let you know of a pretty
remarkable
um thing that we're doing for the John
deloney gang the people who listen to
the show
all right so here's what I take
um every day of the week
I take
creatine
creatine however you want to say it I
take vitamin D K2
I take fish oil take the Super EPA
B12 grasseton CoQ10 and a few others
here and there but the big ones that I
think every single person should take
creatine
B12 fish oil
vitamin D I think most people should get
that from going outside and living an
outside-ish lifestyle if you don't you
should take vitamin D K2 as well
um and K2 just helps with transport
that's a whole other conversation
um
the rest of these the Q certain the
CoQ10 are things I've dialed in with my
doctor over time
um it just helps with my particular set
of genetics everybody in the booth take
something different but everybody also
circles back to
vitamin D fish oil B vitamins and by the
way I give those to my kids every day I
give my kids fish oil I give my kids B12
and I give one of my kids a half dose of
creatine in the morning
and at night here's the big one helps me
with sleep
I credit
and we can disagree all day long
um I credit over time over about a year
of taking
um
several of these supplements for healing
my anxiety helping me learn to sleep
again and I've tested my sleep with
whoop strap and things like that so
here's what I take at night
I take full spectrum hemp oil which has
been a game changer for me
um it does not have any THC in it or
anything like that it does have CBD in
it a little bit but it's full spectrum
hemp oil and I credit that with a lot
it's helped over the years now I take it
once or twice a week maybe three times
on a wild week but I don't take it every
day I did for a long time I take Gaba
250
and I take
phosphatidylserine which isofose is as
Thorn does it's an anti-stress which is
pretty incredible and magnesium by
glycinate and I take those with some
almost every night if not every night
and I tell you what my sleep falls off a
cliff in a pretty impressive way
um
they've become an important part of my
overall health routine
um I've got a special cabinet for all
the shenanigans I've got up there I've
started recently messing around with
Thorn they've came out with a powdered
greens product which I like and I've
been taking that and I take a couple
other things here and there just to test
and see what it's doing but over time
here's what I've seen increased
cognitive functioning increased energy
throughout the day
and increase depth and length of my
sleep and those three things being able
to think clearly being able to have some
energy throughout the day and being able
to sleep
um are the three most important factors
of my life and by the way I'll say this
um
there is a number of studies that talk
about the importance of fish oil and B
vitamins when it comes to low-level
depression anxiety other things so those
are definitely conversations to have
with your doctor so here's the deal that
um it's been two years in the making
um I was you notice I don't recommend
supplements on the show which is weird
everyone's always talking supplements
all over the place and I've turned down
a number of opportunities with different
supplement companies because I'm very
particular about what I take and I
wanted to make sure if we're going to do
anything it's going to be what I take at
my house what I give to my kids and
that's thorn
Thorn because they're pure because they
spend money on external testing because
they say they are who they say they are
and by the way in dealing with a company
the people behind the scenes they're
great human beings like they're not
scumbag companies they're not fly by
nights they're in this for the Long Haul
um they're expensive there's no question
about it and so the way supplement
companies usually
um the way they work on podcast is it's
a REV share split right so you buy
something with the code deloni on it and
I get a piece of it and they get a piece
of it the cool part is about Thorn is
they let me set my discount as high as I
want it just cuts out what I make here
and we all met up as a team and I am
much less concerned about making a bunch
of money on this than I am about people
in your home like everyday moms and dads
like you everyday brothers and sisters
and sons and daughters like you
listening to the show who are either
dabbling in supplements for the first
time or who have been is taking crap for
a long time and it's not doing anything
for you
I'm I'm interested in helping you change
your life in the way that me and my
family have been able to do over the
years and I also know that not
everybody's blessed financially just
have a billion dollars to blow on um
supplements all the time so
um here's what we've set up for you if
you go to thorne.com
t-h-o-r-n-e.com slash you the letter u
slash deloni
thorn.com you slash delonia if you're
watching this on YouTube it's in the
lower third and if you listen to this on
podcast there's a link in the show notes
you're going to set up an account which
is going to take three or four minutes
and then you're gonna get 25 off
everything some people like yeah you get
free shipping dude I'm gonna give you 25
off because it's less about me making
money I've been blessed um y'all have
been supporting the show buying books
y'all been taking care of us and so this
is really our way of taking care of you
guys 25 off everything in your account
that you buy and it's a good way to get
going to help your family get on the
supplement train if you're going to or
to start taking a few supplements that
are of great quality I always recommend
that nobody put anything into their
bodies without checking with their
doctor first if you have a relationship
with your doctor if you're taking other
things if you if you're also taking
other medicines please please don't put
medicine don't put supplements in your
body until you uh meet with your doctor
um
but this is the this is it this is the
big reveal
um this is the conversation about
supplements if you want to go down a
rabbit hole again there's Andrew
huberman there is Peter attia there's
some other folks in the space that are
great resources Lane Norton
um the Mind pump guys we'll talk about
them occasionally there's lots of
discussions out there about why to take
what to take and what it does to you at
the biochemical level
um
that's not what I'm really interested in
right now I'm really interested in you
and your family being as well as you
possibly can having energy being able to
sleep and being able to think throughout
the day go to
www.thorn.com you
deloney for 25 off everything
we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back let's go to Gray
in Tampa Florida what's up gray
how's it going Dr Don deloney I'm John
but good man how are you
that's what I meant
very cool uh what's up dude how are you
things I was gonna say um was you you uh
you have permission to call me on my cow
pies so you already started with that
we're off to a good start excellent hey
uh real quick you're there in Florida uh
did y'all make out okay y'all doing okay
I live about an hour north of Tampa so
we were okay but uh with my job I'm an
electrician I've been down in in the
thick of it all week and it's pretty
pretty heartbreaking yeah well thank you
for being one of the linemen out there
working
um I know you guys are working around
the clock to get power restored to that
community so thanks for your for your
service my brother
you know I'm not a lineman but I do all
the commercial stuff so as they bring in
power I'm there to uh uh to help get it
going awesome make sure everybody's safe
inside well thank you so much man all
right what's up how can I help
okay
um
you're gonna have to kind of bear with
me through uh
through this
um but first i'm gonna give you
permission to speak into my life
um so
awesome I have I have a daughter
um who's five years old
and she lives in Alabama with her mom
and stepdad
okay last year
my daughter's mother reached out to me
and asked if her
husband could adopt my daughter
um having me sign over asking if I would
be willing to sign over my parental
rights
and uh
allow him to adopt
foreign
rough time
um like I got that that text
um yes she sent it in a text that's a
whole another story but uh she sent in a
text as I was pulling back in the
driveway from my little brother's
funeral
okay so I I didn't have time to coat
couldn't cope with those two things at
once and now it's been some time and uh
I don't know how to walk forward on this
I have been out of my daughter's life
um
for most most of her life after
um
the the court and uh
I don't know the proper term here so
forgive me but after
paternity was established right before
my daughter turned two
um I did have a relationship with my
daughter we would video chat pretty
consistently
um
I would talk to my daughter's mom on the
phone probably three or four days a week
and video chat with my daughter a
minimum of two days a week for about a
year
and then my daughter's mom thought it
would be best for her to only have one
dad in her life and that wasn't me
so she hasn't wanted me a part of my
daughter's life for the past
about two two years
and uh
I haven't gone to a court system to try
to fight and that's kind of what I'm
calling about is
I don't know if it's
right to to to fight and go through the
Battle of custody
um
when I've seen how my daughter's mom
reacts to her
her son's
father my daughter has an older brother
um the same mom and uh they they dealt
with that and
even though the courts did get involved
it still wasn't a good situation for
nearly anybody
um and I don't know the ramifications of
of that on a kid my parents were
divorced and lived in different states
for a little while
um
but I also
grew up in the home with my mom and dad
until about
Middle School
so it was a bit of a different situation
there when's the last time you've seen
your baby girl
um four years ago why
one is
I'm
I haven't been in the area and I haven't
been why why
this is a particularly hard call for me
because I got a six-year-old little girl
uh and I I know that's why I gave you
permission to speak to my life and I
knew it was going to be hard well I I I
I I so yeah I'm just going to be direct
with you
um
I've I flew my family out to be with me
this weekend while I was doing an event
in Los Angeles and they came and we ran
around town and it was fun
and then they flew out a day early
because I had an event to do
I I almost woke my daughter up last
night when I got home
and it was 24 hours
I don't breathe well when she's not
around
the idea of going four years
intentionally
like bro I'd be mowing yards in Alabama
dude I don't know what I don't know I I
can't wrap my head around it
psychologically
so why haven't you seen your daughter in
four years
I don't have a good answer for that
um every every time I have
attempted it has been shut down
um
with
um you're you're not your
your daughter's dad anymore and hey hold
on we don't want her to know about you
well she's gonna know about you so
that's I I know I know that's the case
but but hold on they are right you
haven't been her dad
correct that's fair you fathered this
kid but you have not been her dad
correct
um
going all the way back to the beginning
it's a lane that she sent this into a
text and you might be the kind of guy
that has to get it in the text because
she's not safe to call you on the phone
or you're gonna act like an idiot or
what who knows man or she's gonna get
mad who knows
um
but if that's what you're if that's how
she felt safest to contact you that's I
mean that's not how I would have done it
but I don't have a relationship with you
and I don't know how you are about
things
um
like I'll be
video chat is not a relationship
correct
um you basically were a television show
for your daughter
with an interactive character
a relationship is showing up and
physical touch and eyesight and letting
her see a part of herself in you because
a part of her is in you
that's a relationship so you
chit-chatted on a on a computer right
but that's not relationship
um
I can be I'll be honest with you this
sounds more about ego than it does about
your daughter
this sounds more like you're struggling
with the fact that you're gonna put a
period at the end of a sentence and let
another man raise your daughter
and if that's the case you need to get
over yourself and let the man who
stepped up to be in her life be fully in
her life
and that's that's what it's about
um so I'm I'm married with a a son
um and we obviously live in Florida
um and
um my wife and I have had a handful of
conversations about this
and
um
the the option is let her her new
husband obviously be her her dad or my
wife and I go all in move to Alabama and
do whatever we can to
to find a way to be a part of my
daughter's life
and I don't know what either one of
those look like and I'm pretty
pretty scared of both options honestly
yeah man you've backed yourself into
quite the corner
um
actually you know what you haven't
you let your daughter go a long long
time ago
um you're trying to reinsert yourself
into her life
um I can imagine your current wife does
she have a hard time with this
yes
I can't imagine being married to
somebody who would let one of their kids
just just roll off
like I would think less of the my
romantic partner does that make sense
yeah
um a little bit more more context
um like I said when the courts
established paternity that was just
before my daughter turned two
um what took so much
um well my daughter's mom and I split up
um
before even the first ultrasound so we
weren't even sure
um
you know it at the time I we weren't
sure if I was even the father no why'd
you wait two years for a paternity test
why don't you get a paternity test the
second that baby was born
because I was terrified just like I am
today yeah dude you're scared man and I
get it but you lost your daughter
I hope the fear was worth it man because
you lost your daughter
and that's a conversation you'll have to
have one day with this little girl who's
gonna say Daddy what was so bad about me
that you didn't show up and you're gonna
have to say well I was really scared
right
yeah yeah that
and I play that scenario out in my head
all the time and uh but you've been
playing it for six years right five
years how old is this little girl
five five geez man
like this is so uh man I'm not gonna
keep saying that I just don't have the
psychology for it
um I
I don't know what keeps you from
knocking off work today and driving to
Alabama and saying Hey I want to have a
sit-down conversation with the other two
grown-ups in my child's life
um and I guess at this point you're
married so bringing your wife along too
and here's a
here's what I can't answer I can't
answer the psychological impact on this
little girl
other than to know it's gonna be she's
gonna have it rough either way
um
I she's going to at some point reach out
to you
um
ah man I'm just thinking about this in
real time dude
um
tell me that it wasn't going to be easy
for any anybody on yeah in in this
situation tell me about this step dad
from the the little I know about him
he's
a pretty awesome guy
um
I uh
he
he's involved in in their Church
um and has has brought
my daughter's mom and daughter into
um a community with faith
um
and he uh
takes
time
um for the longest time I worked nights
and he works nights also and it's just
really hard on her body and he would uh
first thing he would do when he would
get home is just spend hours playing
with uh
his our daughter and uh
he's I don't have a bad thing to say
about him
um is it shaming to you that he's been
more present in your daughter's life in
that way than you have
100 okay
I'm just gonna run through a couple of
ideas man but I'm telling you right now
I'm recommending things that I would
never do okay
is that cool okay
um
I can see a scenario where you drive to
Alabama and you meet him
for breakfast or lunch somewhere
and you get to know him
and you sign over parental rights to him
and ask permission to write letters the
idea that they're going to keep her from
knowing about you is false that will not
happen she'll figure it out and if they
lie to her
um it's no good
but if there's a way that in 15 years or
seven years or whenever they have this
conversation she's five so it should be
it should be now right
um
that there is a backlog of letters from
Dad talking about how much
he loves you
or loves her and
how much he supports this man raising
his daughter
um I could see that being one scenario I
can see another scenario where you
foreign
yeah where you pack up everything and go
to Alabama probably what's going to
happen is she's going to take you to
court and you're going to lose
maybe not but that would be my guess
or you'll get every other weekend and
then you're gonna be seven months into a
new State trying to find work and it's
going to be a mess
yeah either either way it's a mess
um
and
and I uh
what do you want to do
it depends on nope nope nope what time
the day you ask me um what do you want
to do
here's what I'm telling you I'm not
going to judge either way right now I've
already I've I've
you can hear my voice I beat you up
enough what do you want to do
I want it
to sign over my rights and have
her new dad
um so when where I walked away okay
sign over the parental rights then ma'am
okay
they'll tell her hard thing it is to do
because I'll say that out loud to to my
wife or
by myself while I'm driving and then
I'll just break down and fall apart
feel like that's the wrong thing then
get in your car and move your family
today man
like you're just like you're wasting
year after year after year just driving
down the same road having the same
conversation with yourself and having
the same reaction do something man
because that little girl's getting older
every day
have you corrected this with your son
yes yeah uh yeah he uh
she has a very present Dad I'm not
Bandit from Bluey but I'm
I'm not either I want to be so bad dude
that dad's incredible dude I I tell you
what that's
that's the The Benchmark that I try to
hold myself to for uh my son it's
phenomenal so
um yeah
I worked a 31 hour shift yesterday and
uh still came home and spent spent four
hours
um playing airplane and wackawaka and
reading books good
um
in it so
I don't know man part
this is the single most conflicted I've
ever been on the show
I I knew it was going to be tough for
you I tried to phrase it in a way that
she was prepared
um no I appreciate it beforehand like
every every ounce of my being says go
rescue that little girl
and every ounce of my being says you
cashed out five years ago dude it's time
to move on
but I know you can't move on from your
daughter
and so I'll say it this way there is no
decision you can make that's not going
to cause people hurt
there's no decision you can make that
you're going to feel great about when
it's over
and there's no decision you can make
that is not going to leave an ache
inside your little girl that she's gonna
have to manage for a long long long time
that ship has sailed
so now it's about making the best right
decision even though it's going to be
painful and even though it's going to be
hard
because it's gonna be painful and hard
to drive to Alabama and say I screwed up
this isn't the man I want to be and I
want to be present in my daughter's life
and you sir have been
an extraordinary man
I honor you
I can't give my daughter away
um but you have my full blessing on
being her her stepdad here
but I'm going to be living three miles
away and I want to see her every week
or
you drive down there and you meet with
the three of them uh with or with the
two of them and you'll have a hard
conversation
and you sign over rights but let them
know I gotta write letters and you got
to read the letters to my daughter
because now y'all are all in this
playing a long game for her
psychological and physiological and
spiritual well-being
and that Daddy Gap is big
the stress that Mom was under for the
first two or three years of that little
girl's life
has altered her biochemistry and it's
going to take a long time to heal
so either way this is hard
and if you son over parental rights it
wouldn't surprise me if your wife would
leave you
and so moving from Florida Tampa Bay one
of the most beautiful places on the
planet to Alabama I can only imagine how
hard that would be for everybody
um
I'm sorry I don't have a clean answer
for you dude
my gut tells me you you cashed out a
while ago
um you cashed out five years ago and the
guilt and the shame of standing in the
shadow of this other guy who stepped in
to help
um is what's keeping you up at night not
your little girl but your ego and if
that's the case Let It Go Let Her Go
live whatever positive life she can
under the loving arms of the sky
foreign
if you're ready to change your life
control alt delete and fix every just
heal everything
and you're willing to pack up a move
across the country and say I'm not
living another day without my daughter
in my life
um
before you jump up and do that you need
to go have conversations with the two of
them because they may be ready to sue
you and take you to court and they will
probably win
but I'd have that conversation all of
this is done in person
on your dime on your travel
um all this is done in person and stop
having the same conversation in your
head over and over and over and over
trying to find a loophole out there is
no way out there's only through
and at the end of the day this whole
conversation is about the little girl
it's about the little girl
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead
take a deep breath because Churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 in MLS
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and are not available in
all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to
Stephanie in Rockford Illinois what's up
Stephanie
hey how are you John I'm good how about
you good thanks for taking my call you
got it what's up
all right so
um I have a teenage daughter uh she is
15
um and about a year ago she was
diagnosed with anxiety and depression
so the reason I'm calling is because I'm
struggling parenting with that okay
um you know how do you
know like consequences and stuff like
that because obviously her health is
more important than the dishes being
done but I still don't want to raise uh
you know I still want to raise a good
human so right
um tell me the origin of the depression
anxiety where does that come from
oh boy I'm so sorry yeah so
so it's all very new
to both of us and
so is she a happy-go-lucky kid and this
was just a left turn
yeah
completely
uh uh
so yeah I'm gonna change her you got
depression you know you got grief you
have it all it's not that it's it's
um
it's not my place to comment on
diagnostics because I'm not in your
sessions and I'm not in her sessions
with whatever provider she's getting
diagnosed from but
grief is hard and complex grief is hard
and I just don't believe this is
personal I just don't believe in
Diagnostics on the back end of such an
explosion in the middle of a home
there is any Behavior she has whether
she's running low or she's anxious
is absolutely normal
you know what I mean
yeah
um I don't know that the diagnostic
helps any
um
so let me ask you this how have you been
tell me about that
um you know she
was
um
hospitalized in January and was she
suicidal as well yeah
um no attempt but
not also was she suicidal uh I guess she
wasn't not acutely but
I guess if she was hospitalized that
means she was pretty far down the road
right
yeah okay does she
want to be dead or does she want to stop
hurting
okay
and do you get the difference there
yes
taken oh wow yeah of course of course
um can I ask you a very hard question
that I don't mean in a shaming way at
all this is just me collecting data okay
has she felt over the last year that
she's got to prop you up too
um
I don't
I don't know I don't
I would like to say no but I'm sure that
there's been times
um
for the most part though I would say no
okay
did your husband was this a surprise or
he been struggling for a long time
uh no it was a surprise
oh boy I'm so sorry Stephanie
so
coming out of the out of the fog I'm
gonna I'm gonna just pretend here that
18 months and there's that gnawing
reality that this is real
and there's that low level
just weight that sits on you is that
still there yeah it just kind of is
um have you had moments where you
laughed and you felt guilty for laughing
yeah
have you had moments where you
like somebody makes your heart beat a
little faster and you feel guilty about
it
no okay
have you been profoundly lonely
um I was okay working on that part good
how do you feel guilty
like you should have known something or
said something or done something
absolutely yeah okay
so here's what we do coming out of
survival
is the sooner you can well number one
you can't rush grief it just is and it's
a pain it just is
it's awful and it's hard and it's right
and it's the worst
and it just is
okay
um
there's some ways to manage it and
there's some things you can do over time
so that when that fog begins to lift
that you could be you can breathe okay
but the quicker you guys you and her do
you have any other kids
no just her okay the quicker you two
recognize that
there's not ever going to be a going
back to normal that we have to change
everything
that everything is new now
that's a horrifying feeling of it's just
a period at the end of a Long messy
weep like weepy sentence
but it's also when the light starts to
come on because now you get to build
what comes next
and what I would suggest is the path out
for your daughter
is feeling like she is participating in
going towards something not trying to
survive something
okay
and what that means is you've heard me
say this a lot and
um I would love to see you try it out
that you and your daughter go to go
somewhere and spend a day or two or a
weekend
and have some sort of ceremony where you
put to bed what was
this was our life and now this is our
life and we get to construct it however
we want and here's the question we're
going to answer who are we going to be
and we're going to talk in that who are
we going to be we're going to be people
who take care of our bodies
so we're gonna go for walks every day
together
and we're not gonna eat pizza every
night like we're gonna take care of
ourselves that's who we're gonna be
we're gonna be people of service
we're gonna be people who think about
other people before we think of
ourselves
we're going to be people who get stuff
done so I'll do the dishes you do this
you does that make sense and out of that
we're going to give ourselves jobs and
we're going to commit to holding each
other accountable
the goal here is little wins
the and the Temptation is
is to say hey you got to do the dishes
she doesn't do them you get mad and that
drives her further into a hole which is
just a normal pattern that parents and
teens have this is just an accelerated
or actually it's a dampened
um a dance that's the same dance right
um
this is going to be a little bit
different this is who we are This Is How
We Do life together now and so she is
going to participate in the life of the
household she's not just going to do
crap to keep mom off her back you see
the difference
yeah
and that starts with you saying I'm
going to commit to
getting well
during the season of grief
your teenage daughter is going to watch
her mom for how she's supposed to act
and I know that's a lot of
responsibility on you
yeah
Pride to you know just get
a station as much
different has she seen you be sad
yeah okay
that's a good thing by the way
giving her permission to feel sad is
okay
letting her see her mom be sad is okay
in fact that's a gift to her
now it's about finding purpose in that
home with this new life you are creating
together
in this conversation you'll have
it would be
where do you want to go to college let's
start having that conversation
what do you think you might want to be
how could we make meaning of dads
passing away
maybe she wants to go be a psychologist
maybe she wants to go to med school
maybe she wants to be an architect who
knows what she wants to do but
let's start looking at what is tomorrow
going to look like and what are the
things we need to do right now
have you sat down and had a conversation
similar to that
no I mean no not
that that one comes
very much harder than the conversations
you can it's here's here's why it's hard
because when your husband died by
Suicide life as you knew it was over
and we focus a lot in our grief on the
person
and we forget or we don't even know that
everything is different
a lot of times people run out and get
remarried within three months or six
months because they're trying to get
back to normal the body's job is to get
back to homeostasis it tries it tries it
tries
and there is no homeostasis here
everything's in Ash everything
in this conversation do we sell the
house do you want to move to a new town
do I need to get a new job like right
we're having those conversations
and she's going to play a part in it she
doesn't get the final say and I would
let her know I'm the mom so I'm gonna
make the final call
but I want to hear where your heart is
she doesn't get everything she wants but
hey how do we what are some things you
want to be who are we going to be we're
gonna go to concerts we are going to do
things intentionally to bring joy into
our lives however hard it will be and
we're going to buy tickets to concerts
and we may listen to two songs we're
just gonna leave because one of us
starts crying that's okay
right yeah
how are you financially
um okay I mean obviously inflation is
not the greatest but
um yeah we're okay have you had to sell
that have you sold the house
no we're still in the house okay
have you considered selling the house
um
I'm to that point that I think I would
be able to okay
um where he died
um was by a tree and that tree just uh
fell
on a random weekend
um and I felt
like I could leave then took it took
that like before I felt like I couldn't
like I just couldn't
um there's something profound about
environment when it comes to grief
mm-hmm
um I'm not saying that everybody who has
somebody passed away has to sell their
house has to leave the state but there
is something freeing about changing the
environment
um changing quite honestly everything
some people stay in the same city and
move houses some people just control all
delete and say I'm gonna go I always
wanted I realize how precious and short
life is I always wanted to be a teacher
I'm going back to school to get my
teaching certificate or I wanted to be a
nurse I'm going to get my Nursing degree
like whatever happens
these are the moments that y'all sit
down and you have these conversations
together and here's why the conversation
with her is so important instead of you
going off and doing this by yourself and
making an announcement
because you get to model for her what
the process of thinking and feeling and
weeping and putting your foot down looks
like
you get to say I've always wanted to do
this and I never did it
and I think I'm gonna go back to school
and do it and it's going to be hard and
it's going to be scary and it's going to
be whatever
but I get to be in control of what comes
next however hard that is
and she gets to see get a picture of
what that looks like because she doesn't
have a picture of what to do if that
when Dad dies by Suicide
right she doesn't have a picture of what
how do you how do you replant after the
forest burns down and that's what you're
going to offer her and by the way you
may not have that picture either
yeah because I mean we really didn't
make any changes you know we just
continued on
without him here yeah
and even if y'all end up in a very
similar situation doing these very
similar things and she's going to the
same school and all that stuff the
exercise in and of itself is valuable
and I want you to also hear the big
picture I have not focused on her
anxiety and depression
those are particular snapshots of a
particular season of her life right now
if she's suicidal she's got to go back
to the hospital if you find out she's
going to take her own life you gotta
call 9-1-1 and do the whole thing over
again okay and there may be more of that
as a 15 year old tries to wrestle with
the overwhelming sense of of dread and
doom and hurt that she's going through
right now
and there may be something to letting
her know
um or guarantee that she's asking
herself what was so bad about me that
Dad felt he had to go
and I guarantee you've asked yourself
that question too
yep
it would really be helpful to her to let
her know that you're asking that
question as well
okay it would also be really helpful for
her to know that
Dad wasn't well Dad was sick
had nothing to do with you
I mean I've tried
I know
but let her know that you're having the
same concerns inside yourself too
I'm so Stephanie I don't think I've done
that yeah I'm I I'm just heartbroken for
you I'm sorry
I'm sorry
well I appreciate hearing though that
you know her anxiety and depression May
uh you know it may be a season it may
not be I don't I don't think your
daughter's broken
I don't think she's malfunctioning
um I think her body's doing exactly what
a 15 year old body should be doing right
now when Dad dies by Suicide which is
every alarm it's got is going off to the
point that the body gets exhausted and
then it runs really low turns everything
off
I think depression and anxiety are on
the same trend line they work together
foreign
and so it's a body that tells me it's a
body trying to figure out where it is in
space
not to mention the hormones and the
growing and all the other things that
come along though just general crap of
being 15 right right
um
you put that on top of I'm completely
untethered
from everything and and
um yeah you got a kid that just wants to
stop everything I just want I just want
to stop
foreign
so let's begin to have a conversation of
what does it look like to rebuild a life
worth living in the shadow of what we've
experienced
and that shadow
is going to be as long as it's going to
be the Shadow's not going to go away but
what you're going to find over time is
that y'all are going to grow Beyond The
Shadow
will always be there
but you're going to find that you grow
Way Beyond that shadow
it's just hard to see it right now
because everything's dark
mm-hmm
this may be a conversation that you have
with a counselor
um I think quite honestly I think you've
been thoughtful enough you've got people
in your life I think you can write this
stuff down and you can take her out for
a girls weekend
and give you all give yourself a moment
to point back to in times this is when
we went out this is when we created this
new family values this is when we
decided what our last name is going to
be this when we decided where we're
going to live for the next year and then
we're going to figure it out after that
this when we decided whether you're
going to college where I'm going to keep
working here this is where we made some
some decisions and we held those
decisions really Loosely because plans
change and grief is a terrible master
but this is when we started looking for
the light again
and this is when that little girl feels
less crazy because Mom opens up and says
hey I'm going through that too
and Dad wasn't okay and it wasn't
because he didn't love you Dad loved you
so much and so for some reason he
thought you would be better off with him
not here
God we know he's wrong on this side of
that choice but
we get to work together to create what
happens next
I'm so so sorry
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we're back
um
hey I just want to be open I didn't have
the greatest answers for today's show
um
with the young man who hasn't been a
part of his daughter's life for five
years
um
there's not a lot of good choices to
make there's just the next choice
um a 15 year old wrestling with anxiety
and depression after her dad died by
Suicide and her mom is struggling
moving forward it's just gonna be hard
um
I love shows when I can just snap my
fingers and say you got to do this or
this and this isn't one of those shows
in both of these situations it's going
to be a long long
slog creating a new life
and I always want us to roll back
whether it's a hard weekend you have or
a hard couple of years you have or you
lose somebody who's important to you or
you lose your job
or you look up and you haven't seen your
daughter in five years
you look up and your husband's passed
away and you're afraid you're going to
lose your daughter too
foreign
and at the end of the day all of us all
of us
can be about building a life worth
living
a new life worth living
it's tough
thank you for being with us don't forget
um go to thorn.com you slash deloni to
pick up supplements and um
I'm just I just know this I'm grateful
for you grateful for you uh the song of
the day is from the great Rod Stewart
songs called missing you and it goes
like this
every time I think of you I always catch
my breath and I'm still standing here
and you're miles away and I'm wondering
why you left
there's a storm that's raging through my
frozen heart tonight and I hear your
name in certain circles and it always
makes me smile
I spend my time thinking about you and
it almost driving me wild
and there's a heart that's breaking down
this long distance line tonight
I ain't missing you at all since you've
been gone away I ain't missing you no
matter what I might say
but he is missing
I'll see you soon